don't live your life full of regrets if
there's something that you want if
there's some passion that you have that
you want to chase you owe it to yourself
to go for it because otherwise you're
gonna spend the rest of your life
wondering what could have happened hi
I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and I want to share with
you the story of Jeff Bezos from
amazon.com Bezos seem to have everything
lined up for him for corporate America
success he went to Princeton University
he got a job on Wall Street he became
the youngest ever VP at that company and
was on the fast track for success in the
corporate world and he left it all to
start a dot-com business selling books
and this was the early days of calm
nobody knew what it was and said Jeff
you're crazy what are you doing you're
leaving this high paying job you're the
youngest ever VP at this company and
you're throwing it all away to start
this dot-com business selling books
online who's gonna buy books online
you're crazy but he had to do it he did
it because he said he would regret for
the rest of his life if you didn't try
he was willing to accept trying and
failing and going back to his job then
not trying at all and having to live
with that regret so he sold everything
he invested his life savings into this
new business he borrowed his
stepfather's 1988 Chevy Blazer and drove
the seattle and started amazon.com now
his dreams came true they may not always
happen but if you want something if you
have a deep passion for something you
have to go for it you have to try you
owe it to yourself to try because
otherwise you will spend the rest of
your life wondering what could have
happened living with that regret of not
giving it your all
if you liked this video please give it a
thumbs up it really makes you want to do
more videos for you and if you have a
comment about this video or question for
your company I'd love to try to answer
it for you if you leave it in the
comment section below I always read
those and I really love seeing them come
in so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
you